merci frédéric d'abord quand tu dis des
spécialistes de la sécurité je précise
d'abord surtout rappelé que ses toiles
comme spécialiste premier grand flic de
france et je te remercie à nouveau aussi
avec le président sarkozy de nous avoir
confié bruno beschizza la réflexion sur
la sécurité avec les auditions
d'ailleurs que nous avons commencé
auprès des syndicats de police et je
vous le dis dès maintenant avant
d'oublier que la convention sécurité
comme vous le savez il ya des grandes
journées thématiques sur les grands
sujets aura lieu le 3 novembre
ici avec évidemment les conclusions du
président sarkozy sur la vidéoprotection
en effet frédéric m'a demandé de vous
faire un petit coup de projecteur
c'est sûrement l'un des dossiers les
plus clivants en matière de sécurité qui
peut nous opposer en effet à à la gauche
dans son ensemble même si on le voit les
socialistes commencent à comprendre que
la vidéoprotection c'est quand même la
solution à de nombreux problèmes au
niveau parisien nous continuons
néanmoins à batailler ferme
particulièrement avec les verts qui que
ce soit d'ailleurs au conseil régional
d'ailleurs ou au conseil de paris qui
s'y opposent de manière systématique
paris a pris du retard nous avons eu un
plan de 1000 caméras en 2009 qui avait
été votée d'ailleurs sur une impulsion à
l'époque de nicolas sarkozy ministre de
l'intérieur et avec le préfet de police
gaudin ce premier plan de 1000 caméras
évidemment était insuffisant il devait
être suivi d'un deuxième plan de même
envergure
évidemment cela ne vous aura pas échappé
entre temps des élections ont eu lieu et
cette priorité là n'a pas été porté au
niveau de l'état et nous avons essayé de
continuer nous à défendre cette idée
nous l'avions fait avec nathalie
kosciusko morizet que je voudrais aussi
saluer aujourd'hui dans le cadre de
cette campagne parisienne valérie
pécresse vient de vous le rappeler dans
le cadre des régionales
c'est pour nous une obligation sur sur
paris donc ce retard est en train d'être
rattrapé j'allais dire à minima puisque
nous venons de voter quelques caméras
supplémentaires dans paris
alors que la préfecture de police
estimait à à peu près
265 de mémoire le les caméras seulement
nécessaire sur des lieux importants
stratégique
seuls 70 caméras ont été validés les
caméras qui ont été validés dans les
nouveaux quartiers de paris
particulièrement d'ailleurs dans le
xvème le 17e et les quartiers qui sont
en nouvel aménagement et sur les sites
sensibles sur le 17ème je vous donne un
exemple nous n'en avons que 12 alors que
nous nous avons le 81e quartiers de
paris qui sort de terre c'est évidemment
insuffisant vous le savez nous allons
avoir la cité judiciaire la direction de
la police judiciaire le fameux 36 quai
des orfèvres qui arrive dans le septième
et ça danse ça crée un grand plaisir à
frédéric et à moi en tant qu'élu du
xviie mais au delà de ça c'est
évidemment une surveillance majeur est à
l'heure actuelle dans l'arrondissement
je vais vous donner un exemple nous
avons le site de facebook nous avons
tv5monde nous avons grand rabbin de
france je dire où des personnalités ou
des sites une communauté juive très
présente des lieux de culte
nous n'avons pas obtenu toutes les
caméras nécessaire à l'heure actuelle
qui permettrait d'être de notre point de
vue mais c'est une évidence en vraiment
en sécurité en sécurité d'autant plus
que vous le savez pendant ce temps là on
met des hommes
les sentinelles devant on fait appel à
l'armée devant des lieux sensibles dont
qui sont en statique
quand nous nous privilégions évidemment
la vidéo protection qui soit celle que
l'on peut faire évoluer et bouger ce qui
s'appelle la tribune ce que je voulais
juste de la vidéo patrouille exactement
pour l'intitulé précis je voulais vous
faire peut-être aussi rappelle aussi
qu'il y a donc la can les caméras qui
sont fixes dans paris vous avez les
caméras qui sont dans les réseaux de
transport particulièrement au sein de la
ratp 250 caméras qui elles servent
seulement pour la gestion sur des
réseaux de transport pardon en surface
et puis vous avez les caméras aussi dans
les ensembles sociaux
là aussi c'est une solution très
importante vous le savez nous assistons
plus en plus à des regroupements de
jeunes et de trafic et c'est pour nous
évidemment la solution pour dans les
certaines cités pour pouvoir surveiller
concernant leur utilisation est lucide
le site ou l'élucidation des faits je
voudrais vous donner un chiffre
important c'est que en trois ans entre
2011 et 2014 et il ya eu avec ses
caméras près de dix mille personnes qui
ont été arrêtées donc vous voyez
l'importance pour la seule année 2014
étaient plus de deux mille trois cent
soixante dix huit interpellations je
pense que les chiffres sont parlants et
ses caméras donc en effet permettent ce
qu'on appelle de passer de la de la
culture de l'aveu à la culture de la
preuve ça nous permet évidemment en tout
cas pour les forces de l'ordre après de
faciliter le suivi des affaires
par ailleurs il faut savoir que vous
avez des caméras qui servent pour les
services d'urgence le central des
pompiers est équipé de caméras c'est à
dire que maintenant lorsque vous appelez
les pompiers il y a une capacité à
visionner en fonction des caméras qui
sont sur l'espace public
l'accident où l'événement qui serait
arrivé sur l'espace public pour voir
l'importance entre la description qui
est fait par appel téléphonique est ce
que l'on peut constater évidemment si
c'est son voie publique dans la
périphérie des caméras mais évidemment à
ce stade tout n'est pas couvert donc je
vous le disais paris et est notoirement
sous dotées peut-être vous donner un
exemple donc on a une caméra nous pour
eux 2027 habitants essaient d'ailleurs
d'autres villes socialistes elle pour le
coup on était un peu plus percutante
comme lyon et strasbourg mais vous
donner un autre exemple qui est celui de
nice dont vous le savez christian
estrosi en est le maire c'est une caméra
pour 340 habitants
donc on voit bien la problématique entre
paris une pour 2000 plus de 2000
habitants et puis pour nice une pour 340
quant à londres londres est la capitale
sûrement la plus sécurisée en matière de
vidéo-protection puisque toute caméra
confondues quelles que soient les
utilisateurs on est à 75 mille caméras
donc le d'autres shu et on l'a rappelé
tout à l'heure en tout cas valérie l'a
rappelé déjà dans un premier temps au
niveau des régionales elle n'a pas
évoqué la vidéoprotection dans le
programme de valérie pécresse
il y a une priorité c'est d'installer la
vidéoprotection dans toutes les rames de
rer et de métro
non pas dans toutes les dents tous les
wagons
mais a minima pour commencer chatrain
doit pouvoir être avoir une rame vidéos
protégées
l'idée étant que ce soit là une rame
identifier évidemment de manière très
visible
à charge pour ceux qui souhaitent ou pas
puisque vous le savez certains estiment
que c'est une atteinte à leur liberté de
pouvoir voyager particulièrement le soir
pour dans une rame protéger ça c'est un
engagement de deux valérie parmi
d'autres en matière de sécurité sur
lequel elle sera évidemment amené à vous
rappeler comme entre autres le contrôle
de le part la carte d'identité car à
l'heure actuelle pour lutter contre la
fraude vous le savez si vous n'avez pas
votre carte d'identité
eh bien vous n'êtes pas donc évidemment
redevables puisqu'on n'a pas la preuve
de votre de votre de votre identité
donc je voulais juste vous rappeler donc
là à ce stade donc les moyens nomi qui
sont non seulement au niveau de la
région mais au niveau de la ville de
paris quand parallèlement l'état par
l'intermédiaire de son ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur cazeneuve nous dit
que la lutte contre le terrorisme est
une priorité majeure
et bien la vidéo protection est sûrement
l'un des outils majeurs de protection en
tout cas au niveau de la capitale
il faut savoir que l'autre jour il ya eu
des incidents concernant le président
hollande et bien il au bout de 45
minutes de vidéo protection pour suivre
ce qui avait créé un incident on a perdu
leur trace mais ça c'est un exemple par
rapport à ce qui peut arriver au
président de la république mais c'est un
exemple qui peut arriver
évidemment dans d'autres situations donc
le coup aussi de ces caméras
il faut le savoir le plan supplémentaire
qui a été tout à l'heure je j'évoquais
tout à l'heure a été un financement de 5
millions d'euros par la ville de paris
c'est juste ridicule je vais vous donner
une comparaison la ville de paris vient
d'accéder à d'acheter dans le 17e
arrondissement un immeuble pour
représenter
pour des logements sociaux puisque la
ville maintenant sur sa politique de
logement
c'est une priorité pour un pour un coût
de 6 millions donc je veux bien qu'on
met en parallèle s'il vous plaît 6
millions pour eux je voudrais pas dire
d'erreur de 14 logements pour être sûr
je ne vous dis pas d'erreurs qui ont qui
sont dans un immeuble et les 5 millions
qui ont été mis sur la vidéoprotection
voilà ayez ces chiffres en tête c'est un
sujet majeur et sa frappe et ça
continuera à faire la différence dans
nos combats parisien mais principalement
évidemment avec valérie pécresse et
pierre yves bournazel je vous remercie
beaucoup